at least 40 people have been killed in a
suicide bombing at a political meeting
in Northwest Pakistan it happened in the
bajau district bordering Afghanistan
more than 200 others have been injured
salahuddin's a security analyst and the
director of the center for regional and
Global connectivity at tabat lab is an
Islamabad joins us live from there good
to have you with us so first of all what
are the clues suggest about who might be
responsible for this attack
well the clues are fairly obvious there
has been a dramatic Clear and Present
escalation by the period Taliban
Pakistan since the negotiations between
the TTP and the government of Pakistan
failed in November of last year they
have dramatically escalated their
strings of attacks across the country
including some major attacks one
particularly in the city of Karachi
another bombing conducted in January in
the city of peshava that killed 84
individuals 81 of which were policemen
so all indications point to the fact
that it is this terror group which has
coalesced and regained quite a lot of
the momentum that it had lost between
2014 and 2018 when Pakistan conducted
extensive military operations against
this group
and that leads us to our to my next
question which is going to be we did see
the the attacks decreased didn't we in
previous years does this suggest that we
can expect more attacks like this and
that the Taliban are reorganized they
have revamped their operations
yes absolutely of
and whether or not they have more strike
capability as well as bigger numbers
there's no question about this the U.N
estimates somewhere between five
thousand eight thousand PDP troops
inside of Afghanistan alone and they are
receiving quite a bit of patronage from
the powers that be inside that country
in addition to that yes there was a
quite a bit of decline in terms of
terror-based violence across the country
when Pakistan really geared up after the
horrendous attack in on December 16th in
2014 that killed 135 children in
Pakistan after which the Bro the the
military came out uh and an extensive
operation was conducted across the
country particularly in the tribal belt
bordering Afghanistan and the group was
very systematically dismantled but since
then especially since 2020 multiple
Splinter factions of this group by some
estimates 20 by some estimates all the
way up to 31 separate factions have
coalesced the challenge the writ of the
government again I want to I also just
reiterate that no one has claimed
responsibility for it so far but given
the string of attacks and especially the
escalation since November it's extremely
likely that it's the same group and I
would also like to add here that this is
not the end of it uh with the election
season looming towards the beginning of
November of this year
we can only expect this to get worse
you're right we should point out that so
far no one's claimed responsibility how
is this going to impact the political
scene particularly the political
tensions that have ranked Pakistan
the political tensions that have ranked
Pakistan have dominated all
conversations irrespective of whether
the crises under discussion are
existential in nature or not in my view
there are two existential crises that
face Pakistan the first one being uh
climate change and the second one being
the rapidly shrinking economy and the
question of the current account deficit
that the Pakistan must solve in order
for it to avoid default security is a
major threat and a major issue but it is
not an existential crisis unlike
Afghanistan Pakistan state is not going
to be displaced by the GDP under any
circumstances they will continue to
wreck havoc they will continue to Target
especially law enforcement and with
elections coming it is now very obvious
that political parties in their rallies
will also be targeted but they're not an
existential threat as far as the
political situation is concerned of
course as is the case with everything
else in Pakistan Point scoring will be
made by opposition parties to claim that
the security situation on the current
regime which goes out of power on the
8th of August so just the a little over
a week now is very very bad and that the
situation was a lot better under their
tenure which objectively true uh is very
uh it completely misses the point and
also is is completely out of context
all right we'll leave you there thanks
so much